it increasingly seems like it is very
dangerous legally to represent the
failed former president donald trump
more of donald trump's lawyers may soon
need representation themselves and as
we've said many times before the real
meaning of maga is making attorneys get
attorneys there's a very interesting
article in salon
legal experts say trump lawyers may need
their own lawyers after doj filing the
justice department on tuesday said in a
filing that trump and his legal team
likely tried to conceal classified
documents
after being hit with a grand jury
subpoena the 36-page filing came in
response to trump's dubious request to
appoint a special master to review the
seized documents details the doj's
evidence of obstruction of justice the
doj filing suggests trump and his team
may have tried to mislead investigators
when trump attorney christina bob signed
a document affirming all classified
documents sought by the archives have
been returned as you now well know and
as was made clear in this viral
photograph taken on donald trump's
cheesy casino rugs in his apartment uh
in florida there are plenty of secret
and top-secret documents that were there
so yes
making attorneys get attorneys and
sometimes i start to wonder
don't they know that the fbi is going to
take pictures and that they're going to
film and that it may come out and you
can't just come out and say we gave all
the documents back there are no such
documents the uh the declassification
component which many of trump's lawyers
have focused on
is a distraction it's not actually
relevant in most of the statutes that
are at issue here and there were lies
told to the fbi by trump and his
attorneys about having the documents
regardless of the classification status
that's what matters and as i told you
before
nobody's been charged with anything yet
but the potential criminal penalties for
some of these things are we're talking
about decades okay as maximum
hypothetical penalties the classified
documents and the non-classified
documents are government documents trump
did not have the authority
to have them at his house the doj makes
it clear they belong not to an
ex-president just because he took him
with him
and um seemingly doing self-inflicted
damage as well just as a reminder we
looked at this clip on yesterday's show
one of trump's attorneys alina habba
putting herself at the scene of the
crime saying i was there i know exactly
what was where
yeah nowhere what what's happened is now
they've put this picture out so that you
would assume and i am somebody who has
been and the press loves to talk about
this especially today i'm somebody that
has been in his office i've seen it this
is not the way his office looks they
give you this appearance that you walk
in and there's these top secret
documents just thrown about a b they
don't understand something could be
marked top secret could be marked
classified the presidential records act
he would have said this is declassified
it doesn't get a new marking all the
time he's left the office it is a
complete public spectacle and i'm not
really going to stand by it anymore she
won't stand by it and yet she may also
soon be a defendant these people truly
are pathetic in that this is the
absolute best that they can come up with
and so
legal jeopardy is going beyond trump
here and of course there's a question as
to if and when anybody will be charged
and even if they are will there be
consequences but trump's own lawyers
increasingly in legal harm's way
and also
the right wing simply can't get on the
right talking point
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10 year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days if you
don't love it but i think you will for a
limited time helix is offering up to 350
off all mattress orders plus two free
pillows at
helixsleep.com pacman it's the biggest
discount they've ever offered the link
is down below